got a great YouTube channel right now
that part Marcellus Wiley Is Here Yeah
what'd it do baby hi buddy good to see
you oh thanks for the free drink of
course I appreciate you pulling up man
um yeah it's crazy because I've been
watching you for so long on TV man like
oh my God
hardcore Sports just maniac and between
your NFL career to your TV career which
is almost as legendary as your NFL
career not a lot of people have double
digit like real runs on TV yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah and I when I think
of like everything you did at ESPN and
then helping build FS1 into what it is
today like
um what's going on right now because
you're obviously not on TV right now no
not right now and maybe not right ever
right no because why I mean yeah I mean
like the YouTube channel is going well
and you can say whatever you want yeah
it's a whole different animal now when
you talk about sports media
um but not to get that deep into it um
I guess to take you back uh I was going
to be a school teacher and I just kept
getting bigger faster stronger ended up
being a football player but my heart and
my mind has always been locked in and
helping others yeah
um forking Road kids uh because I was
that kid growing up you know and I
didn't think I was special and I don't
think in those terms that you got to be
special to have success right it's just
a science to life that you got to make
sure that you buy into and follow your
passions and properly enhance your
talents and things go well for you and
that could look a lot of different ways
for me it was going to be working at La
unified right in the ninth grade
somewhere all right man that's that's
all I needed
um but things took different turns and
detours and you know happy with my
journey
you fast forward from there so I had
this moment where I'm getting recruited
by all these schools and everybody's
like oh where you going where are you
going where'd you go to high school at
in Compton uh no I didn't go to school
at because you grew up in Compton yeah
so I'm from Compton born raised there to
like age five age six then we move off
Slauson and greener pastures okay and
that turned into South Central so yeah
my family just kept going to other
places my grandmother from watts to
Compton mother Compton South Central
um I went to Westchester for two years
Saint Monica's had to get up super early
five in the morning to ride with my mom
all the way out to Santa Monica
um so I was gonna be the school teacher
man and then all of a sudden I'm getting
recruited by all these schools and it's
for football and just growing up the way
I grew up and knowing I've seen more
talented guys than me right knowing uh
kind of the hood tales that go on you
know this guy didn't make it all this
guy came back with an excuse all this
guy said coach tripping I just kept
hearing it and um I decided to go to
Columbia so I go to Ivy League school
and it was a roll of the dice people
were like oh damn you ain't gonna go to
the NFL from the Ivy League school and I
was like all right I'm not the type that
cares with people's right good or bad or
more I add up those with me and not
against me so then you you fast forward
I do get drafted I get drafted second
round I play 10 years and then I had
that moment again where I was like I'm a
broadcast now people think about it in
different terms than they did back then
right 2006 2007 if you were a
broadcaster there was like a stigma
almost like damn you just finished
playing ball and you're gonna spend all
your money you got to go work again
right right a little of that Magic
Johnson certainly helped and a couple
other people that you get Jalen Rose was
around back then you know
yeah so it was kind of like weird oh gee
John Sally on the Best Damn Sport show
remember that yes so I used to go and he
didn't help the narrative because people
were like oh John Sally he was kind of
like bouncing around right right right
he wasn't the best yeah yeah you see
what I'm saying yeah and it was a weird
place and I'm not slighting anybody I'm
just telling you how the landscape was
and I it was real resistance like I was
telling my boys in the locker room in
Jacksonville dog I'm about to go
broadcast for what you're supposed to go
somewhere and mess with girls and get
fat and golf right and I was like dog I
can't do that so I rolled the dice there
and then everything took off from there
working that NFL Network ESPN Fox and at
this I just right now I'm in my Columbia
slash broadcasting slash independent
world now where you got to roll the dice
and bet on yourself because I just see
how everything's getting fractured right
now yeah no I think that that's like uh
if anything even like me because I
traditionally worked and I'm still on
the radio every night here in LA but I
do it my own way they they contract my
show I'm syndicated so I don't record my
show from wherever I'm at but it's like
I feel like nowadays if you're gonna be
a part of media or create content like
that is if as long as you're good and
you're and people are interested yeah
like I feel like you got to kind of do
what you're doing do what I'm doing it's
like build your own platform yeah man
and I'm late to the game even though
some people are saying I'm still early
because I mean you're relatively early
you look at guys like Pat McAfee is like
the guy you know and like the bar stool
guys but like you're pretty early yeah I
mean in terms of like platform like you
know McAfee unintended consequences like
he wanted to work at ESPN Etc didn't get
the opportunity thank God right and so
he had to you know he was forced to do
it his way yeah um I wasn't in that
position I'm not in that position now
but I just saw the rewards not only in
terms of on the extremes the success
like you know him or Joe Rogan or Nepal
Brothers like just damn but more than
that they were doing it their way
they're authentic and from what I was
doing and I see it happening now with
Stephen A Smith
when you do Network TV no matter how
real you are it's coming off fake like
people ain't feeling you like you think
they're feeling you yeah and there's and
you still can't be 100 honest right you
have to still be very aware of yeah and
it's not just corporate sponsors and
partners that's the lazy layer everyone
thinks it's better that nah it's because
of who you're working with so you got
teammates when you do it that way and
your teammates
to protect them from looking bad or
losing or them at times you
you got to play this game where we can't
go all the way I can't I can't disagree
with you to the fullest like I would in
real life right like don't I don't
believe that that's some [__] yeah
but then you know in the air it's like
you can't say that you gotta be
political you got to be it's for the
sake of good TV you gotta you know yeah
you gotta let them represent the other
side even though you're like there's no
other side on it right right so I got a
little fatigue to that a little law of
Association because if you let stuff
live then your brand how people really
process you becomes this hybrid of who
that is who that is who you are and it's
like it's just too much gumbo and I was
like damn I'm not as authentic in
reception as I thought I would be at
this point in my career like 48 years
old been doing this 20 almost 30 years
and cats is still not understanding
purely what I'm about right they were
like oh I like you from Sportsnation you
were funny but then on FS1 y'all were
too deep and I'm like dog I'm funny and
deep what the hell you're like they try
to splice you both yeah yeah so I got a
little fatigued that at the law of
Association I would say the same thing
at ESPN the same exact thing at Fox and
one of them was like whatever and the
other one's like oh you sell out are you
mean or you change are you different so
I just kind of got tired of being washed
away with all that I was gonna say have
you watched uh because I just saw
Stephen A replied to Dan levitar I saw
that you saw that and he's he's gussing
and [__] he's going in and I was like oh
[__] I was like Steven A Smith is uh
he's unraveled I love it like but he
wouldn't be able to do that on TV that's
to my point man it's a whole different
animal so you know you kind of get to
just be undressed you know you get to
walk around the house [__] baby boys
want some breakfast like that's a
podcast to me and I was getting jealous
when I was at Fox no lie I'm watching
Jason Whitlock who left
um regardless of the content I just like
that no no but he has his own his thing
he's got his name yeah yeah and I was
like damn and I was watching all these
other cats out here YouTubers moving in
my neighborhood and I'm like damn it
took me 10 years of football 20 years of
broadcasting these suckers and moving in
next door I was like yo the game
changing for sure when am I gonna bet on
myself at 48 or 52 when I get fat and
full again and then you know it was a
hybrid you know Fox and I discussed a
couple of hybrid situations but I'm so
focused on my family like to a point
where I don't like to travel at all and
people like damn you wanna go here go I
don't want to go on the boys trips no
dog I don't did all that plus yeah
you've already done it all yeah and then
get caught so I'm like I'm living
um I want to be with my kids I want to
help raise them I don't want to provide
for them right but I'm distant right in
that yeah because I feel like when
you're a certain level of success that
era has to kind of happen right it's
very rare that you can be super present
and still but like I feel like once you
hit that Comfort area where you're like
hey like now I can really apply myself
to being at home and yeah because I did
all the tough work 20 years ago 10 years
ago yeah built it